good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
thursday the first day of the latter
half of the week we made it to the
latter half
we made it to the latter half we are
over the hump it feels
so good we're just sliding into friday
sliding into friday and and that's
really the feeling that you're always
looking for which is why
here and now we need to acknowledge the
space that we're in because you guys it
really doesn't get much better than this
because you know what i love wednesday
because let me hear
this great darius rucker song
so beautiful so we were talking before
the show and i think that
based on what you told me good mood
claudia has left
the building yeah she's definitely not
on the premises
but she's been escorted off the property
that feels good i didn't like her no
yeah she was annoying as [ __ ]
and i'm just like i'm battling i don't
know what it is like
this entire week like this little flu
like like
not to be dramatic like a little cold
you know yeah you can't just like throw
the word
i know i know i took it back this second
i said it um
just like a little a little it's a
seasonal change like
i do tip like remember in the fall we
got kind of sick we came back from
newport as the seasons were changing
not covered related like people do get
colds they they happen
i know i'm like embarrassed to admit
that i'm like not feeling 100
because people are like you get it yeah
no i'm vaccinated
you're all good i'm all good so i'm just
like it's been bothering me like waking
up like with a dry throat and dry nose
and then like you know justice for ben
because i know i said a few days ago
like i definitely am getting my period
i've just been in like
mood swing central and ben is fully on
the receiving end of it and like
honestly he needs it no no i've just so
like my mood today to answer your
question
it's very we'll see how it goes like i'm
very in the middle i could be taken to a
better place and i could definitely be
brought down
into the pits of hell okay but i think i
have some stories for you that are super
neutral like won't get your
gears grinded we'll get my bragas in a
twist won't get your rockets in a twist
and might even might even be some good
news i have one story of good news that
i'm so excited to share with you because
it might be
my favorite like um story ever it's like
uh
we're not world news but like a
miscellaneous news item
and it might be my favorite story ever
okay well we'll see how it goes i mean i
do
have a lot to say about the new jersey
reunion and the premiere of beverly
hills
so with those types of things i feel
personally invested in a lot of them and
like i'm really feeling like i'm gonna
get angry
oh okay okay that's good that we have
this warning
now um how was your mood today
my mood is pretty good i'm filming a
what i eat in a day vlog which is really
turning into for me like a day in the
life
while i eat vlog um so that's been like
a fun pep in my step this morning just
like i felt like i wasn't alone because
i was vlogging you're never alone when
you're vlogging
100 and you're never alone when you're
with christ 100 speaking of christ you
know what i listened to this morning
the francesca battistelli album so you
treated yourself there's no excuse for a
bad mood i treated myself and honestly
the mood i was in before and the mood
i'm a now i'm still in a bad mood but
two totally different moods because for
chedda francesca badistelli
like brought me to christ and back oh
okay so like you're better than you were
yeah all because of francesca oh well
you didn't share that with me i forgot
i was listening to our nashville
playlist which is so good it's just
good mood good vibes and yeah my what i
eat in the day vlog should be up by the
end of the week so head over to
patreon.com morning toast
where we posted a podcast episode
yesterday answering every single one of
your questions about our national trip
who planned it itinerary price like all
the details
like mvp lvp how did grandma like me
keep up with these
crazy kids who was the chookiest spoiler
alert we refused to answer that
um it was actually really fun it was fun
to relive the trip
and if you had like if our small recap
on monday did not suffice
head over to patreon.com morning toast
because we're just like getting into
every single detail hour by hour minute
by minute of our nashville trip yeah and
if you're looking for some inspo on
planning your own girls trip we gave
really specific recommendations for
restaurants activities
companies to use companies not to use
activities to do activities not to do
yeah the pedal bike so like and
takeaways like things
that we would have done differently um
if we knew yeah but there weren't that
many but there were some key items
yes two specifically so patreon.com
morningchost what is patreon if you're
asking it is a subscription service 7.99
per month you get five extra episodes
from jackie and i
their vlogs their podcast episodes they
come out five times a month and you get
access to our last remaining facebook
group once you become a member as well
so it's a great way to get more content
if the free toast every day doesn't do
it for you
and it's a great way to just support
your favorite gals support your local
thirst monster
yes definitely we feel supported by the
patreon community
the patreon community like dead ass is
why i get up every day
no i i feel you that's what that's what
motivates me that's what fuels me
inspires excites me
patreon excites me page like the i
actually literally got
up today like two patreon to patreon and
i was having already such a fun time
showing you guys what i eat in the day
why
it's the pritikin eating plan and i just
want to say if anyone's been updated i
guess i'll share more of the updates in
my blog about like how it's been going
because i've now it's now been a month
since i've since i've been doing this
and the changes are happening good so
i'm going to share the specifics on this
vlog
patreon.com morning toast what was that
link again patreon.com
the morning toast thank you i almost
forgot we also shared everywhere that we
shop for the trip and just like some
good
shopping tips and tricks so also i got a
new phone yesterday i feel like
i just feel like a new woman like me my
big like samsung
galaxy like it's huge it's iphone 12 pro
max my old phone stopped charging
oh remember when i was on the plane and
i was like jackie none of the chargers
are working
like it was my phone it wasn't the plane
oh wow and then when i got home like
none of the outlets i reset
i went to my circuit breaker and reset
my entire house's electrical box
just to find out that my phone was
broken not the outlets wow i used three
different chargers
so apple delivers i got a phone in two
hours isn't that crazy that never
happens for me
but you know what like spending as much
as i did like it should have been one
hour
for real like they have some nerve to
charge what they charge for cell phones
these days i know but people will pay it
uh hello i'm the [ __ ] who did um and
i'm i don't know do i like do i look
different with my new phone it's like so
big i'm just like hello
yeah new phone energy is like i'm just
like yeah i'll
oh yeah i'm in the middle of something
guys i'll just talk to you like tomorrow
oh my gosh she's so clingy yeah no that
was a big phone call by the way
i know some people like you know my
lifestyle like you could have thought
that it was real
um no i'm happy for you i'm happy for
your new phone i totally understand like
the change that's overcoming you
um i was like embarrassed to be walking
around with an iphone 11 when like i'm
supposed to be like this digital
like queen connoisseur entrepreneur and
it's like i'm running around with an old
iphone
and then i'd be at like dinners with
like other influential successful people
and then they haul
i had because you know my lifestyle and
i
and they all had iphone 12s and i was
like walking around it was like
last season's prada shoes you know yeah
it's embarrassing yeah it's embarrassing
so i'm glad that
you got that fixed up even though like
we're definitely between new phone
models right now
i know apple's going to announce the
latest soon especially because the new
phone that just came out like wasn't any
different from the phone section before
it's
like whatever's coming next is going to
be like big and bad like tesla season
um but no i'm so happy for you they have
to stop like they need to give us more
space between phones
and also of course you know my iphone 11
started to malfunction because the
iphone 12 came out like the second tim
cook got on that skate stage with his
little turtleneck
my iphone was like or like stopped
working you know
having to restart all the time they
always pull that [ __ ] yeah yeah i'm in
that phase right now even though i got
this phone
in when i moved so december december i
got this phone they just
already there's a button the way i have
a chain because i'm young and cool
yeah i got one too i copy jackie it's
from shopjill and ally
yes by the way um there must be a button
in apple headquarters like the day that
they have those quarterly what are they
called
um where they like the live the live
stream where they like show all the new
products
for the upcoming season i think it's
just like fashion week
no no no it's called like new friends
like yeah you know it's like
apple live events no but it's like a
thing where they like i know exactly
what you're talking about it's usually
in september
and he gets on stage and he's like a
little you know clicker for the
powerpoint presentation let's see let's
someone's listening to the podcast like
screaming at us what it's called
yeah and now all of a sudden my wi-fi
stopped working apple event apple
apple uh fiduciary report yeah yeah no i
know
keynote okay sure that didn't like do it
for me sure allegedly
um they must have a button in
headquarters it's like once that thing
starts they push the button and all the
previous models of all of their products
just start to like
airpods haven't worked since the day the
new airpods came out but i will not
give in with a new iphone like iphones
are so important like okay
they're scamming me and i'm okay with it
with airpods like i spent
150 on a pair of headphones like you're
to last till the day i die yeah and
you're going to like it
yeah you're going to like it my my
earpods are always acting up but i
refuse
the battery life lasts like 30 minutes
now yeah we can't even do a podcast
like remotely and have the when the
airpods die
the episode yeah crazy it's so annoying
i think it may be going back to like
headphones plugged in yeah do you know
that when you get a new iphone which is
insanely overpriced they don't give you
a charger they just give you the cord
they don't give you the block and they
can twist it over there and by the way
it's a new block you know it's not like
the usb one anymore it's a ucb
they're so [ __ ] sick and twisted i
can't
it's it's actually unethical like i
think that the
i mean there's so much about their
practices that are unethical what is the
company the block is not like the
tipping point
like the fda no like the bureau bi
no come on better business bureau thank
you the better business bureau the
triple b's
need to infiltrate apple because there
are so many unethical business practices
coming out of that
trillion dollar company and i think that
it should be investigated
and i'm happy to take on this project
yeah no no like the investigation would
be much wider than just them not giving
you a block
no but that's the start of it yeah
that's the start of it that's like the
red flag
right that is the one thing that opens
up the whole you don't make millions yes
ai
yes it's like college admission scandal
the guy in the sec i have a better story
for you
it is the the charging block is the key
to like the data encryption or whatever
like
atrocities they're committing yes
there's more there's more
so i got a new phone so that's your
daily investigation
and i feel like get to work you guys
everybody
call the police by the way we had a
toaster who wrote into deer toasters
because her husband works in the fbi he
doesn't have
any social media if you're listening to
this episode can you flag this for your
husband maybe he can open up an
investigation in his specific fbi bureau
yeah yeah yeah for sure just a thought
just a thought
it's nice to have listeners in high
places other than those thoughts
anything else from yesterday that you
want to share before we dive into today
no i'm really excited to recap all the
housewives last night was like
such a big night for housewives yeah no
it was really exciting of course i had
such a busy day yesterday i can't think
of one thing
no me neither not not one none not one
well we recorded the patreons
oh we heard a patreon and i was on the
treadmill for a while just you know
doing my thing
and i'ma do my thing and
yeah that's the latest with us not much
so i think without further ado
do where are you right there he's right
there being perfect
so sweet so cute everything of the sword
i wish seo could like i could
communicate with him like i need him to
lay strategically it's
summer my thighs are showing i need him
to lie in a specific way that covers
just like the bottom half of my
thunderous thighs
and he's doing it right now so i just
need him not to move okay perfect
without further ado where are you he's
right there like we just said
here are the past size stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
ancestry.com have you ever wanted to
know more about your family history but
thought it would take too long
ancestry is a feature called story scout
that can help you dive in fast
wouldn't you love to know more about
your ancestors what they did how they
lived their struggles
what do you want to know what it would
feel like to discover family you never
even knew existed
so basically ancestry is your family
history search
simplified a lot of people don't know
about their grandparents lives but
ancestry is a feature called story scout
that can connect you to a whole story
about an ancestor's life starting with
just a few simple details so you can
learn
what your grandpa's life was like in the
depression where he lived maybe even the
street he lived on
you don't have to be an expert
genealogist or even know much about
family history to build a family tree
quickly on ancestry
with just a few facts you can start a
tree and add it to a add
to it with a hint feature that leads you
to your family you might even connect
with other people who share common
ancestors with you
that'd be crazy i feel like me and
gwyneth paltrow definitely share answer
i have to
check that out with ancestry but i feel
like there's definitely a way yeah
even if if you've done your family
history before the little leaves called
hints on ancestry
can lead you to discoveries in minutes
imagine what it would feel like to click
on a hint and find something amazing
that quickly
what would you want to find in a
60-second discovery i don't know that
maybe i'm related to like
queen elizabeth um now you can get
stories about your ancestors for free
with just a grandparent's name and a
place they lived
at ancestry.com toast
that's a-n-c-e-s-t-r-y
dot com slash toast um check it out
learn more about your family it's time
it is time
it is time okay first story a little
family news riverdale's kj apa a little
family news brought to you by
ancestry.com yeah yeah that's where i
was going slush toast
riverdale's kj apa is expecting the
first baby with model clara berry he
says that she
is pregnant the riverdale star revealed
on wednesday that his girlfriend is
pregnant sharing a photo of the 27 year
old model
showing off her bear baby bump as the
couple lounge on the couch
she also confirmed the pregnancy by
sharing several maternity shots on her
instagram
to which appa replied she's pregnant by
the way
lol i didn't even know he had a
girlfriend happy for him hearts are
breaking everywhere because like you
know
should have been us but it's fine it's
fine i'm really happy for him they've
been together for a while now and so
you know proof is always in the pudding
and i'm totally here for this couple and
i and i love
you know new family news she's wearing
this new fendi
design have you seen this no that's like
it's like um
hypnotic like oh like a zig zaggy like
ziggler
yeah like um futuristic like ooh yeah
have you seen that no oh you haven't let
me show you because i want to get
yourself no like i
i know what you're talking about i
haven't seen it like in the store and i
don't know oh no i've just been seeing
it on instagram and stuff and it gives
me a headache
yeah um i just like
like that oh i don't like that no no no
no no no no no send it back okay now
send it back
return return to center i'm really happy
for him i mean i literally did not even
know he was in a relationship
and i don't know who this girl is but
like for a couple of people i don't know
pretty happy for him yeah and like just
for the kids and the teens like again
like good sweet teen news okay so even
though like you're ready
not teens right right so ben platt
playing uh dear evan hansen is an
atrocity
mackeja app is like fully having a child
and he's almost 30 and he's playing a
riverdale high schooler
yeah yeah he's 23 though oh yeah she's
27.
oh yeah so and when he got the roll i'm
sure he was out
maybe 19. i take it back i take it back
i just assumed he was also like 27
ish yeah he gives me 27 vibes but he's
23 which is crazy that's so young yeah
so young but okay so the point i was
just trying to make
redacted retax return to sender take it
back
escort it rewind escort it from the
premises literally
get it off the property it's a
trespasser
okay mazel tove exactly are you ready
for our next story
i am fans are losing it over prince
william's
buff arms prince william received the
first dose of the coven 19 vaccine this
week and shared a photo of the moment
but more fans seem to be struck by his
buff biceps
than his receipt of the shot one person
commented those guns though another said
ladies focus please
i'm blushing someone else said no wonder
the duchess of cambridge always looks so
happy
lol so yeah no this is kind of shocking
because like right well they obviously
released the photo not for this purpose
to like encourage people to get
vaccinated
um a hundred percent and we were just
like sidetracked by this big arm
i disarmed because like when you think
about prince william like you don't
really think like you think
this man is in the gym like tearing up
swole season not even that i never even
thought for one second what his biceps
looked like because
they were just in my mind so
unremarkable like yeah because he just
gives off this like dad vibe like
yeah and he's like he's got the balding
hair learning how to you know be a
monarch i don't think he was spending
his time in the gym you know and he
doesn't really focus
no offense clearly on like physical
appearance or else he would have gotten
hair plugs like years ago like
he's a monarch he takes himself
seriously his job his commitment to the
country
his family harry is like you know the
young hot thing i'm sure
harry gets his hair cut all the time and
works out in the gym like
before he left you know obviously now he
has a lot of free time but before i'm
saying
yeah so i just never even thought to
like think of what you know prince
william looked like without a shirt on
and now that i have this small visual
i am like you might see i'm liking what
i see and i think i need to
know more yeah i think i need to see the
other arm for starters
yeah for starters isn't it kind of crazy
that um
prince william like just got the vaccine
are you like really delayed in london or
is he just like being
you know let the others get it first oh
yeah maybe they don't have it open to
like his age
they hadn't had it open to his age group
yet nobody also i don't know
even outside of the pandemic the royals
are permanently social distance like
they should be the last people on earth
to get it because they don't ever see
anyone you know they like live in their
castles
yeah but no but they go and do the tours
and you know are always
meeting and greeting so if they want to
get back to that yeah i'm just
wondering like if when did the queen get
it
do you see the queen's dog died she got
it like in the way beginning oh good
okay yeah did you see that the queen's
dog that she got as a gift
for five months ago when uh when the
other one
when the dashing died yeah and it was
like you know like when
i can't [ __ ] speak prince philip was
like getting sick and stuff he just died
wait she got a dog five months ago yes
and what kind of dog
you know one of her dogs one of her dogs
she's like those breeds who was like
five months old yeah
did they say what what cause i only read
the headline but it was devastating that
is really sad
i know and also how neglect
and accident health health who knows you
know it's very exciting
honestly like when i grow up i wanna
have the same health care as the dogs of
queen elizabeth
i mean do you still they lit oh so true
but most of them live forever yeah no i
feel like
theo would be if he ever like wants to
like serve
and protect like he would be a great
queen's dog
no and this specific queen already is
thank you you know my lifestyle
no i agree like i think that if queen
elizabeth like really wants a true
companion like she can get all the dog
she wants but the dog for her is
actually sitting
right next to me it's true and i respect
the queen so much
i actually would because theo would have
a better life like
running around and also he was meant to
be a royal so he's a direct descendant
of queen victoria's original
cavalier yeah so i think it's only fair
that
queen elizabeth takes her thumb on
theo's forehead
yeah no that's what would be best for
for everyone involved but
she hasn't asked yet yeah and i'm not
just gonna like roll over there and hope
that she says yes you know she's gonna
have to come to me
100 i'm not desperate i mean i am a
little desperate you know my lifestyle
yes we we are very familiar anyways
that's what's going on under prince
william's sleeve
and it's good to know the more you know
truly more you know and it
it's cleared me from these photos that
prince william is rising and grinding
and that's actually true and i'm happy
to see it
yeah and he's staying he's up in the gym
working on his fitness
kate says literally i was going to say
that
are you ready for our next story sure
it's a little good concert news
gcn gcn lollapalooza 2021
lineup is released it is happening end
of july megan the stallion post malone
foo fighters miley cyrus the baby
journey and more will be headlining
lollapalooza is returning to grant park
for its 30th anniversary july 29th to
august 1st
the festival returns at full capacity
after a year away due to the still
ongoing coven pandemic attendees at this
year's festival must be fully vaccinated
or provide a negative covenant 19 tests
obtained within 24 hours
of each festival day oh torture um
i'm so glad like this is like a true
signal because i feel like this is
festivals should and would be the
absolute last thing to come back because
it's
pandemonium even not in a pandemic like
so many people rubbing sweating sharing
drinks yeah
like like in pre-pandemic like there was
herpes going around yeah you know so
they're already like a cesspool of
viruses
so i feel like the fact that one of them
is starting to come back it's a really
good sign
um that lineup actually sounds good i've
never been to lollapalooza but i'm
always like
we should go yeah we actually should
yeah i don't
i don't know about that and also like
i'm not crazy about like a festival in a
city i know that's why i'm that's like
my only kind of like
about it yeah no but i hear you i agree
like we should go to a new place and
experience like new things but i don't
know about in a city
i know it's a lot but happy for all the
performers pop stars
do aleppo with the baby um and i just
think it's going to be
really exciting for the people that do
end up going because as much as we say
we're definitely not going so
no no we're not going but i'm really
excited for those i do and i'm excited
for you know what this might herald
and like lalapalooza has like a cult
following you know like people who go to
like lala that's what they call it
yeah um it's like the same way we feel
about stagecoach so we should be happy
for them and hopefully they'll be happy
for us
if and when stagecoach ever decides to
return when it's our time but
just like the san francisco 49ers it is
not our time right now but maybe one day
maybe one day
are ready for our next rates about our
favorite pipeline the colonial
is it the colonial pipeline news that's
brought to you by manscaped yes
yes i've got a pubic service
announcement for everyone the manscaped
engineering team has confirmed that they
have successfully created the lawnmower
lawn mower 4.0 trimmer it is now
available for purchase in usa and canada
this new trimmer was just released only
moments ago and we are the one of the
first to get our hands on it and share
the news
you can join the over 2 million men
worldwide who trust manscaped with this
exclusive offer for you
20 off and free worldwide shipping with
the code toast
at manscaped.com we got our hands on the
uh 4.0
uh lawnmower oh well not we ben did
and we got our hands on it and then we
handed it and they handed it ben has
been obsessed with manscaped ever since
they sent us their products like
six months ago and this new trimmer is
bigger and better and
it's a great gift for the man in your
life also it's a gift for yourself too
you don't want to be whacking weeds down
there so yeah
yeah um so how it works is they have
ceramic blades and skin safe technology
it is too good
to be true it it's as if manscaped works
worth
worked with elon musk's engineers to
ensure your testicles are as safe
as possible gives you the ability to
turn on the 4000k
led spotlight you can get it on and off
when you need a really precise shave the
new trimmer even allows you to customize
your trim all over to additional guard
lengths with sizes one through
four you can get twenty percent off and
free shipping with the code toast at
manscaped.com
it also comes with wireless charging it
uses electromagnetic induction
which can help battery length last
longer if you're still filming
if you're still trimming your face with
your ball trimmer it's time to make some
changes
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code toast at manscape.com if you don't
want to end up with pubes in your mouth
yeah
no that's that's a no that's reason
enough also father's day is coming up
and so that's also a good gift
oh yeah i guess for your husband who's a
father like
also like for your child yeah no it's
like but you don't have to get into the
details of what it is like it's
manscaped it's yeah
it's for your escaping yeah no but like
no matter we could do like the coolest
stuff on earth cmas who's coming on the
show blah blah blah the coolest thing
i've ever done is brought home manscape
for my husband no totally
literally are you ready for our next
story about the colonial pipeline our
favorite pipeline what's going on with
the drama so the drama
has subsided but now it's turned out the
ceo is letting us know joseph blount
that he paid the ransom to the hackers
and he decided pretty much day one that
he was gonna do that but i thought
you're never supposed to negotiate with
terrorists apparently a lot of people
with these cyber attacks are just paying
it because like it's not worth the
trouble
it's not worth the trouble but then it's
like okay so he said how much should
they want
four point four million dollars is what
they got they should have asked for more
yeah i'm kidding the operator of the
colonial pipe i learned was in trouble
at daybreak on may 7th when an employee
found a ransom note from hackers
on a control room computer by that night
the company's chief executive
officer came to a difficult conclusion
he had to pay
joseph brown ceo colonial pipeline co
told the wall street journal that he
authorized the ransom payment
of 4.4 million dollars because
executives were unsure
how badly the cyber attack had breached
its systems and consequently how long it
would take to bring the pipeline back
so if he paid it and paid it pretty
early like
why was there even an issue like why was
there an outage for a week
well because it had stopped while the
while the hack i just have to say like i
actually have a lot of like respect for
this i know like i think like
isn't it like you're not supposed to pay
ransom that's what they do on svu yes
he said he said i know that's a highly
controversial decision yeah i didn't
make it lightly i will admit that i
wasn't comfortable seeing money go out
the door to people like this
but it was the right thing to do for the
country right so that's what i'm saying
so even though it was probably like a
difficult decision and
i don't know if it's like the ethical
one i do have respect for the fact that
like
he just didn't want this to go on any
longer and displace all these people
yeah because if you don't have gas of
course it's like
when we were talking about it i'm like
okay yes whatever but then being in
nashville and like being somewhat
affected by
like the shortage i was like people
depend on this
not only to get to and from it's their
work so i actually
think that this was the right decision i
know it just you know sets a bad
precedent right and it's like the
principle of it like you're not supposed
to
pay the ransom it's like you don't
negotiate with bad people
they're the criminals here mm-hmm but
there's so much at stake what do you do
i don't know what i would have done
i don't know i better make sure it paid
to give away four million dollars i
appreciate the honesty
oh by the way i do too because i was
curious they're like oh it's fixed
but how now we know now we know and
that's where the wall street journal
article ends if you don't pay for the
subscription so if you
said anything additional you can check
that out in your subscription but i
think
like i just want to let you guys know
that he paid the ransom and he's letting
you know
i find these like publisher
subscriptions to be so annoying like
first of all like get over it you know
like we're living in the digital age
like just get over it
um and second of all i also feel like a
lot of times they like put
the paywall up on like really like juicy
stories that like
exploit people's like trauma almost and
it's like you're profiting off of
like that business insider piece that's
david dobrik yes that was like
really traumatic for the people that
spoke up like was behind a pay wall i'm
like
really you're profiting off of someone's
trauma just feels weird
yeah no i i feel that i did i don't know
how i feel but like i just
do you pay for any just patreon.com of
course
and um i subscribe to a sub stack and
but no no like major
like wall street journal or business
insider prime no no no neither no no oh
no um but you don't read that much news
yeah so no but also so much news is free
right it's like why bother
yeah are you ready i guess you could say
the same thing there's so many free
podcasts why would you
pay for patreon because it's the most
premium content you'll ever see no we're
going behind the scenes
and also like if you want to see us or
like do something or answer a specific
question like direct access
there's an accessibility there's an app
for that patreon.com are ready for our
fifth and final story which is maybe my
favorite story i've ever read about
heroic campers is it the final story
to do okay a school bus driver in south
carolina is crediting his precious cargo
of 18 elementary schoolers for foiling a
hijacking with any without anyone
getting hurt
a man with a rifle boarded kenneth
corbin's bus looking for a ride to the
next town 20 miles away
an animal an animal this man hijacked a
school bus said his name again
uh the name of the uh hijacker hijacker
was not what i said that i said the name
of the bus driver which was kenneth
corbin who's the hero here who's the
hero
the man boarded kenneth's bus looking
for a ride into the next town 20 miles
away
but he only made it six minutes until he
gave up in frustration
when the kindergarteners on board
wouldn't stop asking him questions
corbin said the hijacker became so
exasperated he pulled over and let
everyone off oh my god corbin and the
kids are being hailed as heroes
so then he took the bus to town yeah i
guess he continued
driving so he he boarded the bus and
there was i guess a scattering of kids
and he made all the kids come up to the
front so he could like keep an eye on
them while he was hijacking
and they started asking him questions
they asked him why are you doing this
he didn't have an answer for that they
asked was he going to hurt them he said
no
they asked are you going to hurt our bus
driver
he said no i'm going to put you off the
bus
he sensed more questions coming and i
guess something clicked in his mind and
he said enough
is enough already okay and told me to
stop the bus
and just get off can i just say this is
such a funny story but we're getting
lost about
i can't think of anything more [ __ ] up
than boarding an elementary school
kid's bus high tracking it with a gun no
it's like it's like
turned into this like a like funny but
oh my god like heart you send your kids
to school
on a bus and you think it's like the
safest place in the world aside from
those back of the bus bullies
and somebody gets on with a gun yeah
like we're skating past that no no but
it's
so that's like the most horrific thing
i've ever heard no i know
but then it's good news because the
power of campers
and their inquisitive nature saved the
day can you imagine how scared that
driver was like with all those kids on
the bus
horrifying the kids are so innocent
they're like
where do we go when we die and you know
what's the moral of the story never stop
asking why
100 and there's no such thing as a
stupid question because a stupid
question could save your life could save
your life that's so true
never stop asking why yeah so that one
goes out to the campers
oh my god i like don't know whether to
like laugh or cry it's so horrible
it's so horrible but it's good news it's
good news because the campers are okay
but like the fact that the campers
were never ever in question ever in
danger it's very upsetting very we need
to protect the campers
i agree and the cameras what an animal
are protecting themselves
that's the thing campers they have the
shield they always protect themselves
yeah let's dive into our tv recap
segment because those are the past five
stories and i feel as though
i do feel as though you needed to know
them um we had the jersey reunion part
one and the beverly hills premiere which
do you want to start with
i'll go in order sequential beverly
hills all right our beverly hills recap
is brought to you very appropriately by
one of our most fabulous sponsors
bluenile.com most fabulous julia i wore
the earrings on the toast yesterday
you can celebrate all of life's special
moments from creating the custom
engagement ring of her dreams to gifting
a once-in-a-lifetime piece
all at prices you won't find at a
traditional jeweler
so if you have a birthday uh anniversary
something coming up where you need to
get a gift for the woman in your life
whether they got a promotion they're
celebrating an anniversary
um check out bluenile.com it is
honestly some of the most stunning
jewelry whether you're making
whether you're marking a milestone or
simply celebrating in general
bluenile.com offers fine jewelry
perfect for every occasion and their
spring jewelry trends are in full bloom
you can easily navigate bluenyle.com
they have thousands of gemstone options
at every price point from textured gold
to multi-color gemstones and classic
pearls you can shop this season's
stunning trends
on bluenile.com you never have to settle
because you can choose from more than
100 000 ethically sourced gia graded
diamonds in every shape
and size with an endless selection of
settings to help you
design the ring earrings or pendant of
your dreams
they have over 165 000 ratings and
counting with over 90 percent
four stars or higher um so
they're the quality of blue nile is
really everything it's super high
quality there's
really reasonable pricing and you can
get anything you want no matter what
your budget is i have these gorgeous
like multi-colored
gemstone little gold hoops and i love
them and they've great customer service
um you can get expert advice 24 7 and
they have 30 day returns
so when you commit to a piece so does
blue nile they have guaranteed service
and repair for life which is unheard of
make the moment sparkle with jewelry
from bluenile.com and morning toast
listeners can get 50
off their purchase of over 500 this
podcast exclusive is only good for the
morning toast listeners
so use the code toast that's t-o-a-s-t
at blue nile dot com
and you can shop stress free free with
guaranteed free shipping and
returns blue nile dot com code toast
blue nile is truly our most fabulous
sponsor
perfect for the beverly hills premiere
the most fabulous franchise and last
night they did not disappoint
no they did not there was like this
eeriness just kind of listening to
everything erica jane said because of
course i'm now listening to it
through the lens through the lens of it
all goes downhill from here
and i did tune in to watch weapons live
after with all the ladies
and auntie announced that erica joy
erica jane would not be joining and that
she's not doing any press and i
immediately turned it off like i'm not
really interested in hearing serena
pretending like she disapproves of
harry of amelia and scott disick dating
i know that's the best thing that ever
happened to her i overheard you
listening to that clip and like the
response was just like there wasn't
you thank you it is what it is and then
andy was like have you spoken to chris
jenner about it and of course like chris
jenner's like lisa rena who
um no they're actually friends no kyle
is friends and i think that they just
did that skims campaign like as a
housewives
because they haven't even spoken about
it and kyle like made this little smirk
um when she was asked that question
because lisa was like no
if they were friends they would have
spoken about yeah oh i thought they were
closer than they are i thought they were
two and then when she said no i'm like
oh this is definitely like a fake
friendship
kyle and kris jenner are actual friends
yeah serena doesn't go to the christmas
holiday party
okay yeah no that's that's a good point
i don't know why i just like assumed
they were friends
yeah no me too um so there's a lot to
unpack of course we have two new
housewives
and i have to admit crystal was not what
i thought she was gonna be
she was like very [ __ ] and i was like
100 here for it yeah she reminded me of
sutton last season like coming in and
just like judging everyone sun was
judging everyone's fashion
and crystal was just judging everyone on
whether or not she's ever heard of them
yeah no it was so interesting but she
was also judging their fashion and she
made some
fair points like maybe it was because
everyone was just in dorit's backyard
that they looked extra ridiculous stupid
yeah but i don't know like i'm always
here for the glam but i was just like
they're a little ridiculous and i felt
that way and i texted you i was like
so and so i was a little too old for
that dress and then literally crystal
said the same thing and i was like
i feel seen they looked a little stupid
like even durian who i think couldn't
look bad in a paper bag
i was like what are you doing like it
just felt a little stupid and i like
that kathy hilton was like dressed up
and then she was like this is insane
when she walked in and everyone was like
fully in their prom dresses
yeah it was a little stupid but the
sutton looked amazing i loved that dress
i loved it no everybody really looked
amazing but together in the backyard
they just look stupid
yeah and it wasn't like jarit's new
house is like nice
but it's not like you know it's just a
weird premise
for like it was a nice idea i understand
but like in practice it was just like
weird like what a waste of that
versace's outfit
um so one of the most shocking things
that i found from the episode is that
sutton is renting kyle's old house
and of course she told me a headline
about it so it didn't shock oh i didn't
know
and of course the headline said that it
has brought them closer oh good i'm sure
like they have to get along a sutton
like when they first said she was
renting i'm like oh my god what she's
like renting permanently
but well of course while she renovates
her six million dollar house so that was
a huge sigh of relief because i was like
nobody beverly hills friends yeah and
she's the real deal except during npk
were renting that house before and they
were but now they own their house and i
love their house
i do too it's not the like the nicest
one but it's the most
no no it's not the nicest one period i
finished my sentence oh i really like
their house i love everyone's house
garcelle's house it reminds me of all
the houses on vanderpump rules
once they like grow up with a little bit
you know like they add an extension oh i
guess so
it's just very basic i hear what you're
saying it's so very like this moment
and it's so crazy how quickly home
trends change and like
i don't think this feels this way about
modern farm house which is like what
dorite and pk have but like
these homes that are so modern in ten
years are going to look so weird
and it's just it's i would never go so
hard on one trend but i don't feel that
way about reed's house i love dries
crystal's house i'm obsessed with like
talk about land like
just stunning i actually really liked
crystal i wish they actually said how
many years were between her and her
husband because they were like making us
do math
he moved to l.a in 1980 is that what he
said
so that was 40 years ago and he must
have been at least 20. yeah so he's 60
and she's in her 30s right he didn't
look 60.
no he's handsome i would say he's
between 55 and 60.
and she's in her 30s yeah yeah if they
hadn't mentioned it i wouldn't have
realized that there was such
many either they look like similar ages
yeah but i
love that he's a lion king man like he
obviously they're extremely
legitimate oh for sure like that pixar
money
is so real it's just like really a weird
dynamic that it's like now she's coming
in and kathy's coming in and they're so
legitimate and they're like
you know frowning on these people who
like we've come to revere
so you know what i was actually thinking
i think beverly hills is getting too
big for a lot of the women and i think
like lisa rinna is like more irrelevant
than ever
well i felt like they were trying to
push like dorit
out the door and maybe even a little
like erica jane too
because they're coming in these are like
serious women and it's like
oh you know you're 100 right like
they've really upped the ante
kathy hilton and crystal and quinn
crystal was like if you don't know
someone it's like you're not worth
knowing
i think that actually is the case for
the industry that her and her husband
operate in which is film like
they're very hollywood whereas a lot of
these other women are really famous
but not in the movie like you know they
probably go to the oscars every year and
i think none of the other women do
so i do think like you're right we've
been elevated to another level we're
actually like losing some of our
favorites like
honestly like having that barbecue at uh
dorit's house after just seeing like
crystals like
you know effortless you know spanish
style ranch yeah
it was just like different yeah it just
like
shot shined a light on like some things
that we weren't seeing like
i don't know i think kyle is like very
much in the center of this social group
now with her sister
and i do think that um kyle's nose
looks amazing yeah i think this is the
best kyle has looked ever ever say that
every season she like really is aging
backwards and i hate when people say
that
but she really is yeah i didn't notice a
big difference but i'm not good at
picking up on like in her confessionals
i noticed
oh interesting i never realized when
like someone's had work done
i love garcelle so much for just like
not putting up with lisa arenas [ __ ]
like i love how lisa reyna's now so
apologetic of all the things
say it to denise she's just like so in
the moment and she and she's so fake
that she thinks having that conversation
with garcelle
frees her of all of it and we're ready
to move on and i love
garcelle for being like no we had to
talk but like and still don't trust her
it's
step one yeah no and when garcelle was
like how are you gonna come like
berate someone who's admitting that what
they did was wrong it's like just like a
weird i mean it's pretty
[ __ ] genius like the way that she
goes so hard and then she just like
apologizes profusely doesn't only when
denise is gone only when
the work is done yeah no and it's like
every season it's a new rina she's
becoming ramona like
last season it was like she had that
breakdown in rome and she was like i
want to be a better friend to you denise
and then literally annihilated her
uh in her living room and then on the
reunion so i don't trust lisa arena at
all
and i just really feel like she thought
like for so long she like hitched her
image on the show to erica jane and now
erica jane is like worried about her own
[ __ ] and i feel like lisa is like
like honestly irrelevant oh interesting
i just feel like she'll always do
whatever it takes to stay on the show
you know so
i guess it would never be boring when
she's around but i understand my
garcelle is like that's not a friend
that's not someone i would ever trust
because she would admit it herself that
like if push comes to shove she might
have to
she might have to turn no and she look
what she did to her friend denise of 20
years yeah
i don't know how anyone could actually
be true honest friends with lisa rinna
snowing what lisa rena did to denise and
even if you don't agree with denise
lisa asked andy to bring denise on the
show and then literally after one season
turned her back on her so completely
and i just don't know how anyone would
actually want to be friends with lisa
arena in real life eight two rina
e to rena so it was a good episode i'm
just ready for like all
of the erica stuff because it seems like
awkward yeah because
it's like she's alluding to some of it i
felt like the way that she was at the
barbecue
the red carpet barbecue was more honest
than she's ever been yeah she woke up
every morning with dread and like didn't
even want to wake up like some days
because the quiet was just too
overwhelming and so that's
i think the most you know she's ever
shared
and then she said something so apt you
know everybody you never know what goes
on
in people's lives and the bigger the
life you have the bigger the problems
like oh [ __ ] yeah i'm looking forward to
seeing how all that is then she also
said spending time with tom at the
breakfast table every morning
it's delightful so i don't know if my
heart is ready to really watch
the d unification of erica's marriage
because
i was always rooting for them yeah me
too do you know what month this was
filmed in like
no what month we're in yeah no i
couldn't figure it out either but i
didn't try very hard
me neither it was all in all just like a
great episode there's even the worst
episode of beverly hills is fabulous
glitz glam fashion outfits
erica and dorit in the mclaren just like
riding down like you know uh lewis and
clark
lewis and clark except no not losing
club i know
thelma and louise thank you yeah yeah no
it was just lewis and clark
that's like american history yeah no
they they explored the west i thought
maybe you know because they were
exploring california no no i meant
bonnie no dumb and louise yeah yeah it
was just
eye candy as it always is and now we
have some new
um people in and i i feel really
strongly about them i do i texted you
last night kathy hilton is candace
bergin in case you were wondering who
she reminded you of i just
placed that one for you um and i'm
really have a positive outlook
me too nothing bad to say like it was
really a great kickoff to the season
and i just i'm so glad my ladies are
back yeah me too
um and then new jersey part one reunion
really got my gears grinded like
the group is so divided and i feel so
frustrated with
the right side of the couch theresa
delores and
jennifer because jennifer's so insane
delores is so
grounded in so many ways and i really
feel like
she just has a really good sense of
right and wrong and she refuses to exude
that
sense of right and wrong on her friends
and it's so frustrating and teresa is
literally the world's biggest [ __ ]
hypocrite
and i need next season in order for like
melissa i think to really
evolve on the show because she's getting
like a little stale she really needs to
and i know it's like family but like she
needs to put teresa in her place theresa
is the worst [ __ ] sister
on the planet i don't know how anyone is
friends with teresa let alone related to
her and forced to defend her
when she's literally never come to her
anyone else's defense in their entire
life and she's siding with jennifer
yeah commenting on jennifer's pictures
there's been all this instagram drama
melissa vs jennifer and teresa's
commenting on jennifer's picture how
does melissa
not [ __ ] go crazy i don't know i mean
she's just like tethered to like
this sense of a family which i totally
understand
but it's one way yeah it's one way it's
a double standard it always
always has been it's infuriating yeah i
can't ima i mean imagine how melissa
feels and but like for melissa like
joe is is priority so like
even though she wants to go in like she
wouldn't put her brother
her husband in that situation let's talk
about the plumber slander
let's talk about it it was so vile and i
feel like really showed teresa's
character
and first of all let's just get the fact
straight
joe benigno is not a plumber and even if
he was why is that a derogatory thing
plumbers make a lot of money i don't
know like the margaret slander last
night like killing me
i wasn't expecting and i was just i was
not here for any of it and like these
i would say jennifer and teresa just
like
i don't i don't even know what's what
but they found a way to like put
margaret in this corner when it's like
margaret is such a good person she's
such a good friend like
how is she finding herself with her back
against the wall and honestly jennifer's
saying that
not only did margaret start the rumor
about evan but margaret also
said to jennifer and like george that
joe gorga doesn't pay anyone like
i just don't believe that maybe i'm like
a margaret apologist but i just don't i
don't believe that margaret would
ever ever confide anything in jennifer
aiden
period especially about melissa's
husband right a hundred percent
and like margaret said if she had said
that jennifer 100
would have brought that up on the show
oh if they were fighting so hard all
season why wouldn't she throw that in
and i do kind of agree
i don't the thing is with what's so
frustrating is like i don't i think that
like what's going on in jennifer's world
with her
mom is really jennifer's business and no
one else should comment on it but
jennifer's the queen of literally
involving herself in everyone else's
business so i actually agreed with
melissa and jackie
like for how they spoke on what's going
on between jennifer and her mother
even though i do feel like it's nobody's
business but like that's what jennifer
brings on herself she's everybody's
business and jennifer brings that on
herself she talks about everyone's
everything look how she talks about
margaret's marriage and margaret's
marriage is not even a story line
right and margaret's marriage like when
she gave that speech at the finale party
like
that's all i ever needed to hear i have
a great idea literally solid
no concern it's so solid and
that's so it's not even a story line and
jennifer's picking at it so honestly
whatever jennifer makes a storyline
is fair game for the other women talking
about picking and i agree
she did throw her mother under the bus
yeah and i would understand why her
mother is upset
of course putting her marital troubles
on national television
yeah so i
and the fact that theresa can't even see
that when when right alyssa was like
would you ever talk to your mother
how jennifer talks to her mother or
would you ever even bring up your mom's
marriage
on tv teresa is so hypocritical she
can't even
see how like blatantly contradictory she
is because theresa would never
ever disrespect her parents right ever
right so it's just so frustrating to
watch it and i just
delores didn't say anything the whole
reunion because her friends are
indefensible
yeah and dolores is such like a i love
delores she's honestly one of my top two
favorites on the show
but her friendship and loyalty to teresa
and jennifer
is so annoying but you know what i
actually
i'm gonna take the other i respect laura
staying out of it because like her
friendship with theresa goes back from
before the show it's like
you know we just said that we're gonna
turn underneath after 20 years of
friendship just for the tv and like
i don't think that she needs to go after
she's
going to call her out i think it's
enough that she doesn't back her up what
about jennifer
jennifer i i don't feel like delor i'm
not waiting for dolores to chime in
okay that's actually a fair point you
know i don't think everyone needs to
have an opinion on everything
you know that's true but in this group
they like do yeah but that's why we love
and respect dolores because she knows
when it's
when to pop out yeah and so honestly for
the most part i'm on the couch the
left-sided couch's
side but with this whole joe gorga and
dolores stuff like joe workers so wrong
100
and honestly like melissa getting so mad
at everyone like getting involved
talking about chauvinism when melissa
was the one running around the party
taking
a poll about dolores relationship like
sorry that's exactly what you get no
like the whole thing was so messy
no one's 100 right in the situation um i
think
everybody knows that joe was wrong to
for the whole dolores conversation was
wrong period on melissa joe and
everybody in the polls side yeah um
but this conversation about joe and
melissa and i feel like they are being
like really painfully honest
so it's like jennifer's argument doesn't
hold anymore that melissa doesn't have
story lines and she makes [ __ ] up for
the show because like when he asked that
was as real as anything i ever saw and
he asked like what do you say to
people who say this is like fake first
storyline melissa was like i wish yeah i
don't know how melissa lives with joker
sometimes he's like so
self-righteous yeah but just and there's
no like
neither of them are willing to bend on
this no and he honestly like is acting a
little bit like teresa
like just not listening yeah it was a
good
uh opener it was i can't wait for her it
was just like frustrating for those of
us
who love and stan margaret yeah because
i by the way
looked and she really described exactly
why she looked so good because her boobs
first of all look amazing and then she
was like my face left like finally
settled in like it does take time
she and by the way i saw her for dinner
a day after the reunion and i was like
oh my god she looks amazing and she had
the same haircut and she looks
incredible
on the union like the best
transformation of all i agree i think
everybody
we all no i really agree i really think
that all
six women looked wonderful jackie's
makeup is a little red
yeah yeah i feel that but general like
some the reunions recently have just
been a mess
and so i think that they all look really
great me too i think it was two really
good episodes of housewives and i'm very
pleased tonight we have new york
wait yeah no we already have you just
watch the kardashians kardashians oh my
god i have so much catching up to do me
too but until we kept backing up to do
tomorrow and other than that friday's
almost here so just get excited get
ready
acknowledge the space that you're in one
more day of alarm living then we have
two alarm free days in case you don't
know how the week works thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennium morning show where
we deliver the past by stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
we're podcasting we found out spotify
itunes central public radio i already
has box all the places where we listen
podcast find us the morning shows leave
a five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are
we hope you guys have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow for friday
friday gotta get down on friday
goodbye goodbye